(upbeat guitar music)
- We just have to see how the
rest of the year is going.
Like I need everybody,
We had that sales dip
with merchandise, probably
(droning buzz)
due to the blizzard.
In February we were
able to get it back up,
but we need to stay strong.
- What's your opinion on kombucha?
- Fungus, or whatever it is,
I had to drop it off at the hotel
and they'll feed it, 'cause
you have to feed it--
(random music blaring)
- Yeah, the date was amazing.
She's like a mix of Jennifer Connelly,
but cuter, if you can imagine--
- Oh my god, that reminds me!
The cutest puppy jumped
in my lap yesterday
when I was in the lobby.
It's that kind of dog you love,
Right, this has nothing to do with
what you were talking about, I'm sorry.
(papers shuffling)
(papers crumpling)
- Hey, I gotta run real fast,
but do you mind emailing Linda
and making sure that she comes tomorrow
and brings the cake and everything?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Cool, thank you.
(bubble bursts)
- Shit.
What did she just say?
- My desk, 10 minutes.
- Okay, okay.
(bursting poof)
- It's been 30 minutes.
- Oh, shit.
Nick, I'm sorry.
- I was in this analytics
meeting the other day,
could not concentrate to save my life.
Swear I have ADHD.
(cartoonish popping)
- I don't know if that's how that works.
(upbeat guitar music)